Speaker 1: All right. We're going to
look at a pretty entertaining but also
disturbing clip today. This is a clip
of Republican Senator Tommy Tuberville.
He participated in a national security
Senate hearing. And it's, on the one hand,
hilarious because the guy can't put together
a coherent question or sentence throughout
his his opportunity to ask questions. At the same
time, it's really disturbing because this is who
the people of Alabama selected to send
to the Senate. So it's hilarious and it's
disturbing. Check this out. The guy can't
ask one question that makes any sense.
Speaker 3: Good morning, Director Haines. In
your best assessment, does Russia intelligence
closely monitor our sector defense?
Speaker 4: I think Russian intelligence tries
very closely to monitor all of our senior leaders.
Speaker 1: Okay. So that so far we're okay.
Does Russia monitor our leaders?
Fine. Now look at where this goes.
Speaker 3: So you believe that noted that
when he or. When he or. Said that Russia
weakened what and that the US will
move heaven and earth to arm Ukraine.
Do you believe that? Right. He should say that.
Speaker 4: Yes, I think. Secretary.
Speaker 3: Do you believe Russia blames the U.S.
intelligence community for helping Ukraine shoot
down a Russian plane carrying hundreds of people?
Speaker 4:
I'm sorry, sir. Can you repeat the question?
Speaker 3: Do you believe Russia blames US
or intelligence agency for Ukraine shooting
down a plane with hundreds of troops on
board? Do you think Russia blames us for that?
Speaker 4: Which plane are you thinking of?
Speaker 3: There was a plane recently that
was shot down. Russian plane. That 100 troops.
You believe that? They blame our
intelligence agency for that?
Speaker 4: I don't know, sir.
Speaker 3: Okay. Do you believe that
Russia blames or U.S. intelligence
for sinking their flagship must
cover? Do you think they blame us for that?
Speaker 4: I don't know, sir. We
haven't seen any direct.
Speaker 3: To what extent
do you access that Russia believes you access?
Speaker 1: I think he means it. I mean, it's I,
I if if he if this guy has a reading disability,
then okay. But as far as I knew, he didn't.
And he's just struggling to make sense with
English words and trying to put them together.
Speaker 3: It it is a war with the West and
the United States. You think that they believe.
Speaker 1: You access it? It is at war.
Speaker 3: They're at war with us.
Speaker 4: Russia has historically believed
that they are in a conflict, in effect,
with NATO and the United States on a variety
of issues, including in cyber and so on.
Speaker 3: So you believe that they're
fighting us, that they're fighting us
as well as they're fighting Ukraine? Correct.
Speaker 4: In a sense, their perception. Yeah.
Speaker 3: Yeah. Because we're arming them and
we're talking. Okay. General Berrier, does United
States or Ukraine have air superiority over the
war zone? Which one has air support, period? I
would call it center. I would call that an air and
air standoff right now. I mean, the Russians can
can fly a tactical aircraft over the line.
Speaker 1: I I guess maybe what he was getting
into the direction of is that. It's dangerous
in Ukraine, like, okay, so I'm going to be as
charitable as I can hear about what Tommy
Tuberville was trying to make evident here.
He was trying to make the case that,
listen, even if we don't consider that we
are at war with Russia, Russia does see themselves
as being in a conflict with the United States.
And we as the United States don't actually
have control of the airspace over Ukraine. So
U.S. officials are shouldn't go to Ukraine
because it's dangerous or something like
I'm trying to make sense out of nonsense here.
But what is clear is that our country is in
pretty serious trouble. This is one out of
100 senators. This is not like, oh, you know,
it's just everybody gets to speak at a school
board meeting and it's just a random person
from the community who doesn't know anything
about anything. This is one of 100 senators.
Random, poorly sized students would have better
and more coherent questions than Tommy Tuberville.
But this is the guy that Alabama Republican said
we want. We want to send him to the Senate. We get
two of the 100 senators. Here's the guy that
we want to send. We're in trouble as a country,
folks. We're in trouble as a country.
And it is looking very, very ugly